[Musik]
was bringt der Ampel asylplan fragen wir
uns heute an diesem Donnerstag und damit
einen guten Abend der Kanzler erlebte
einen sehr historischen Moment ob das
gleich historisch ist wenn Politiker aus
Bund und Ländern wieder einmal versuchen
Ordnung in die Zuwanderungspolitik zu
bringen geben soll es jetzt weniger
Leistungen für Asylbewerber und mehr
Geld für die Länder ansonsten viele
Absichtserklärungen und selbst daran
schon viel Kritik auch aus den
ampelparteien wird sich so die Zahl der
Menschen die ins Land kommen verringern
lassen historisch oder halbherzig was
bringt der Ampel asylplan das fragen wir
uns und diese
Gäste Niedersachsens Ministerpräsident
Stefan
weil J östemir dem grünen Bundes
Landwirtschaftsminister Carsten
Linnemann dem CDU
Generalsekretär
der migrationsforscherin Victoria
rietig und der Journalistin Eva
Quadbeck sie sind zu Gast bei Maybrit
ner und die begrüß die Gäste
ausgesprochen herzlich nachts um 2:30
Uhr war die Sitzung der
Ministerpräsidenten mit dem
Bundeskanzler zu Ende die Ergebnisse
sind unterschiedlichst eingeschätzt
worden der Kanzler spricht von einem
historischen Moment Länder und Kommunen
werden finanziell entlastet
Asylverfahren beschleunigt und
Leistungen für Asylbewerber
eingeschränkt so der Plan die Ergebnisse
sind nicht zufriedenstellend wir hätten
uns gewünscht dass es weitere
Entscheidungen gibt zu denen
offensichtlich der Bundeskanzler aber
auch die SPD geführten Bundesländer
nicht bereit waren immerhin ist der
Kanzler bereit zu prüfen ob
Asylverfahren außerhalb der Europäischen
Union möglich sind
z.B in Afrika viele der Dinge die
gegenwärtig öffentlich diskutiert werden
würden aktuell mit dem EU-Recht nicht
vereinbar sein das sogenannte Ruanda
Modell wird nun nüchtern geprüft
vorangetrieben hatten es Großbritannien
Dänemark und Österreich bislang ist aber
noch kein einziger Asylbewerber dorthin
gebracht
worden der CDU Vorsitzende fühlt sich
ignoriert seine Vorschläge zur
Migrationspolitik hat Kanzler nicht
berücksichtigt damit ist das Thema
deutschlandpakt zum Thema Migration aus
meiner Sicht
erledigt damit müssen wir anfangen und
also mit cararsten Linnemann dem
Generalsekretär Hendrik wüst hatte das
Ergebnis dieser Unterredung Herr
Linnemann zunächst gelobt und für
wegweisend gehalten Daniel Günther
ähnlich Herr rein ähnlich
wer hat Friedrich März jetzt diesen
deutschlandpakt versaut waren es die
Ministerpräsidenten der CDU oder war es
der Kanzler nee wir sind da völlig einer
Meinung dieses Ergebnis ist gut gerade
für die Kommunen die warten seit Monaten
auf eine Finanzspritze die brauchen das
Geld weil die Flüchtlinge da sind aber
wir wollten ein Stoppschild für die
illegale Migration und jeder weiß ich
habe heute noch mit Bürgermeistern
telefoniert sie fragen Landräte jeder
weiß dass das nicht funktioniert dass
wir weiter die illegale Migration nach
Deutschland sehen und wir brauchen
eigentlich einen Kurswechsel und dieses
Papier ist kein Kurswechsel deswegen war
ich ziemlich irritiert dass der
Bundeskanzler das als sehr historisch
bezeichnet als historischen Moment warum
redet Friedrich Merz dann dennoch so das
Ergebnis schlecht wenn sie sagen sie
sind da eigentlich alle einer Meinung
nein also das was inländisch jetzt
passiert ich meine die Kommunen es gab
ja so ein Gipfel gab es ja vor vor ja
halben Jahr im 10 Mai seitdem warten die
Kommunen a auf das Geld und jetzt kommt
etwas das ist richtig und wir machen
auch ein bisschen was beim Thema
Abschiebung und hier und da aber
eigentlich braucht doch dieses landen
Kurswechsel wir kennen so viele Experten
und alle sagen das gleiche dass wir ein
Kurswechsel brauchen dass in Zukunft nur
noch Menschen zu uns kommen die bereits
einen positiven Asylbescheid haben und
das sagen alle Experten von Herrn Knaus
bis zu Herrn kobmann und während Corona
haben wir immer die Experten alle hier
gehabt die hatten unterschiedliche
Meinung jetzt haben die Experten eine
Meinung und deswegen brauchen wir diesen
Kurswechsel okay und sie wollen sich
weniger auf die Beschlüsse fassen oder
mit denen befassen die jetzt in
Deutschland selbst getroffen wurden
sondern mit denen was an den
Außengrenzen passiert war denn und das
ist ja interessant dieser Vorschlag von
Hendrik wüst zu sagen wir wollen
zukünftig auch ermöglichen dass in
Drittländer abgeschoben werden kann und
außerdem in diesen Drittländern
Asylverfahren stattfinden können unter
anderem Ruanda wusste Friedrich Merz das
genau richtig was hendri wüs sagt und
das bestätigt auch Friedrich Merz das
steht auch in unseren 26 Punkt sagen
alle Experten dass in einem Drittland
das Verfahren stattfindet sie sehen es
jetzt ich habe eben noch mit Manfred
Weber telefoniert Albanien macht es
gerade mit Italien in Zukunft sollen die
Flüchtlinge die in Italien ankommen nach
Albanien gehen dort findet die Prüfung
statt und wer negativ beschieden wird
wird von dort zurückgebracht und wer
positiv beschieden wird darf nach
Italien das ist doch Humanität dann
kommen doch wirklich diejenigen die auch
Unterstützung brauchen jetzt kommen doch
nur die starken die jungen Männer
richtig war friedich also sagen sie
schon ganz lange richtig war Friedrich
merärz eingeweiht in diesen Plan von
Hendrik wüst das Holter die Polter in
diese Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz zu
tragen ja klar Fredrich MZ hat das Thema
auch beim Bundeskanzler angesprochen wir
hatten zwei Tage vor der MPK ein Tag vor
der MPK abends noch eine
Präsidiumssitzung wo wir da drüber
gesprochen haben frauner das ist alles
nicht witzig wir werden in 10 Jahren
hier noch mal sitzen und uns die Frage
stellen was haben wir damals gemacht
wenn wir jetzt kein Kurswechsel genau
nein historisch ist das was vor 34
Jahren passiert ist der Mauerfall sowas
ist historisch aber Prüfaufträge und
dieses Papier als historisch zu
bezeichnen wo es kein Kurswechsel gibt
da können wir mit ist Stefan weall dran
wir sind dankbar dass er uns
zugeschaltet ist aus Hannover er war
dabei und hat her weil das ist
interessant sehr früh zu verstehen
gegeben dass ihnen das überhaupt nicht
gefallen hat was die sogenannten
b-länder da auf den Tisch legten nämlich
diesen zusätzlichen Vorschlag das und es
ist eigentlich so gar nicht ein so neues
eine so neue Idee dass
Asylverfahren nicht nur an der Grenze
Europas stattfinden könnten sondern in
sogenannten Drittländern Ruanda wird
diskutiert andere Länder auch warum sind
Sie da so sicher dass das nicht
funktionieren wird und warum lässt sich
der Kanzler dann drauf ein also zunächst
einmal unsere Sitzung hat deswegen so
lange gedauert unter den
Ländervertretern weil da ganz viele
Punkte neu besprochen werden sollten
gemessen an den Beschluss den wir drei
Wochen vorher einstimmig schon
beschlossen hatten das war der
eigentliche Punkt was jetzt aber die
Drittstaaten angeht da habe ich
überhaupt kein Problem damit wenn
Asylverfahren in anderen Ländern
stattfinden und das spricht auch vieles
dafür die eigentliche Frage stellt sich
für mich bei Menschen die schon in
Deutschland sind verbringen wir die dann
gegen ihren Willen in irgendein anderes
Land z.B Ruanda also an einem völlig
anderen Teil der Welt und vor allen
Dingen auch was passiert denn dann in
den Fällen in denen die Asylverfahren
abschlägig beschieden werden lassen wir
sie dann in Ruanda oder was passiert
dann und auf diese Fragen habe ich bis
jetzt noch keine vernünftigen Antworten
gehört und ich glaube es hat schon
seinen Grund warum dieses Modell
jedenfalls einwe noch nirgendwo
durchdekliniert worden ist übrigens auch
die Frage welches Land wird wohl auf
Dauer zusehen dass Menschen die keine
Perspektive in diesem Land haben aber in
diesem Land bleiben sich dann von Tag zu
Tag
in dieser Art und Weise dann auch
offiziell vermehren wir sehe schon wie
schweres wir es haben also ehrlich
gesagt ich glaube nicht dass darauf
wirklich Segen liegt aber jetzt ist es
geprüft dann mag es geprüft werden und
an der Diskussion wird man sich
beteiligen es ist tatsächlich richtig
dass die migrationswissenschaftler der
Meinung sind dass das gelingen kann
beispielsweise auch in einem Land wie
Ruanda wenn man es eben nicht der
Regierung von Ruanda überlässt diese
Prüfverfahren durchzuführen sondern es
das UNHCR machen lässt oder auch eine
europäische Organisation noch mal die
Frage warum ist der Kanzler gestern noch
so kritisch gewesen und lässt es heute
prüfen Sie denken einfach nichts ist
mehr undenkbar und wir prüfen das jetzt
und wenn es sich einrichten ließe dann
würden wir auch das tun nein also mein
Wunsch war das nicht dass das drin steht
und zwar deswegen weil ich noch
nirgendwo eine einigahermaßen für mich
einleuchtende Antwort auf meine Fragen
gehört habe aber jetzt ist es so
beschlossen und der gesamtbeschluss der
ist so wichtig dass ich es jedenfalls an
so einer Frage ganz bestimmt nicht
scheitern lassen wollte denn das ist für
mich das entscheidende historisch würde
ich jetzt auch nicht sagen das war ein
langer Abend aber ob es ein historischer
Abend war ist eine andere Frage aber er
war wichtig weil wir nämlich einen
gemeinsamen Kurs zwischen Bund und
Ländern besprochen haben und uns dabei
in vielen Fällen auch sehr ernsthaft in
die Pflicht genommen haben und das ist
das entscheidende dass wir jetzt
wirklich praktisch Vorankommen das haben
wir uns sehr fest vorgenommen dass sie
sich gegenseitig in die Pflicht nehmen
3,5 Milliarden mehr für die Länder
allein zur Versorgung der Flüchtlinge
Eva Quadbeck ist bei uns vom
redaktionsnetzwerk Deutschland
Chefredakteurin Leiterin des
hauptstadtsbüros meint die SPD dieses
prüfen Frau Quadbeck weil es gerade so
diskutiert wird meint die SPD dieses
prüfen ernst oder ist das in diesem
konkreten Fall auch ein politischer
Trick gewesen also im Moment habe ich
nicht den Eindruck dass ernsthaft
geprüft werden soll so hat sich der
Kanzler auch nicht eingelassen
interessant ist ja dass diese prüfoption
auch im Koalitionsvertrag steht also SPD
Grüne und fd DP hatten sich darauf
verständigt dass das in
Ausnahmesituation so heißt es im
Koalitionsvertrag durchaus möglich sein
soll und deshalb konnte die
SPD jetzt auch nicht umhin der Kanzler
nicht umhin das eben auch in so ein
Papier reinzuschreiben weil das ist ja
sonst schwer zu erklären dass das was
man im Koalitionsvertrag stehen hat
nicht auch in solch ein gemeinsames
Papier mit Bund und Ländern
reinschreiben kann jetzt ist die Frage
wäre die interessante Frage wie
eigentlich das Innenministerium agiert
ob es da möglicherweise Interesse gibt
doch ernsthaft zu prüfen und die Fragen
die Herr weil gerade aufgerufen hat die
sind ja alle komplett berechtigt und
beispielsweise ginge es gar nicht solch
ein Modell zu fahren ohne in Deutschland
eine Stichtagsregelung zu haben und zu
sagen diejenigen die schon hier sind die
können natürlich nicht nach Ruanda
Albanien oder sonst wohin gebracht
werden fürs Asylverfahren die deren
Verfahren muss in Deutschland geprüft
werden man kann aber sagen ab einem
bestimmten
Stichtag von da an werden die Leute in
ein anderes Land gebracht und ziel eines
solchen Abkommens ist es ja ja nicht
dass man dann
100tausfachantträge prüft in einem
anderen Land sondern Ziel ist ja dass es
ähnlich eine ähnliche Wirkung gibt wie
beim eu-türkei Abkommen dass die
Menschen sehen sie kommen nicht weiter
das ist quasi eine Sackgasse wenn sie
jetzt sich nach Europa aufmachen und
sich überhaupt nicht mehr in ihren aus
ihren Heimatländern aufmachen das ist ja
das eigentliche Ziel das dahinter steht
wenn man eben über diese
drittstaatenlösung spricht man muss noch
mal dazu sagen Großbritannien hat das
vor Jahren vor zwei Jahren beschlossen
hat im letzten Jahr als einziger Staat
bisher auch Menschen nach Ruanda bringen
wollen und schon einen Flieger besteigen
lassen um dann von eu-gichten davon
abgehalten worden zu sein und dennch
weiter um dieses Modell zu ringen wie
gesagt mittlerweile dreht sich da was
und es gibt eben auch nennenswerte
Migrationsforscher die sagen das könnte
ein Modell sein wenn nicht die
Regierungen dafür verantwortlich sind
noch mal zu dem Gesamtpaket Frau
Quadbeck würden Sie sagen dass das
wirklich auch eine inhaltliche Wende ist
was Bund und Ländern da geschehen ist
und und was zwischen Opposition und
Ampel gelungen ist also ich finde schon
dass das substanzielle Beschlüsse sind
die in dieser Nacht getroffen worden
sind und man sollte sie auch nicht mit
das ist jetzt alles viel zu wenig klein
reden ich kann mir schon vorstellen dass
sie in der Zusammenschau auch eine
Wirkung entfalten da sind die
Grenzkontrollen drin da äh ist das
Signal drin dass diejenigen die als äh
Asylbewerber oder auch als geduldete in
Deutschland leben äh 36 Monate geringere
Leistungen bekommen als das Bürgergeld
und ähm das hat natürlich
eine Signalwirkung und es ist auch in
Ordnung dass Deutschland sich durchaus
ein wenig an das europäische Niveau
anpasst was die flüchtlingsversorgung
angeht und was man auch nicht außer Acht
lassen darf das Wohlstandsniveau in
Deutschland ist insgesamt in den
vergangenen Jahren ja nun auch gesunken
die Sozialkassen sind ja lange nicht
mehr so voll wie sie ehedem waren und
dass dann der Staat sagt wir können die
Flüchtlinge nicht mehr in diesem Umfang
und auf diesem Niveau versorgen wie wir
das bisher konnten das hat seine
rechtigung auch wenn es eine harte
Entscheidung istm Jim östemir ist bei
uns im Kabinett dieser ampelregierung
und bis 2018 Parteivorsitzender der
Grünen ausgerechnet aus diesem aus der
Parteiführung kommt von ricarder langen
jetzt Kritik an diesen am Dienstag
gefassten Beschlüssen sie sagt weder bei
den Kürzungen für die Asylbewerber geht
sie mit Leistungskürzung aus 18 Monaten
mach 36 Monaten noch kann sie sich
vorstellen dass es diese R Lösung gibt
glauben sie dass dieser Beschluss
innerhalb der Grünen überleben wird oder
wird er innerhalb der Ampel überleben
wie weit werden wir damit kommen also
erstmal ist ein Kompromiss zwischen Bund
und Ländern und wir sollten jetzt
erstmal schauen dass wir das was wir da
beschlossen haben prüfen umsetzen und
schauen welche Wirkung es entfaltet
manche Vorschläge sind jetzt nicht
Vorschläge der grün gewesen die kommen
eher aus der Ecke von Herrn Linnemann
andere dagegen sind Vorschläge gewesen
die die Grünen wollten das ist
beispielsweise dass die Leute arbeiten
weil wir der Meinung sind das ist besser
für unser Land wenn sie nicht staatliche
Hilfen brauchen sondern frühzeitig
Arbeiten zum Lebensunterhalt beitragen
sorgt besser für die Integration und so
wie bei jedem Kompromiss ist es am Ende
nicht schwarz nicht rot nicht grün nicht
gelb sondern von allem was werden sie
für beides Senkung der
asylbewerberleistungen aus 18 Monaten 36
Monate machen wo man aus dem asy
leistungsberber Gesetz bezahlt wird und
erst dann diese sogenannten
analogleistungen bekommt und so Hilfe
bekommt und sind dafür haben wir das
haben wir mit Bund und Ländern so jetzt
verabredet die
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz und der
Bundeskanzler beteiligt waren ja auch
der Vizekanzler und der Finanzminister
also die anderen beiden
Koalitionspartner auf im Bund und das
werden wir jetzt wir sind
vertragstreuschrittweise umsetzen was
diese Frage angeht
es geht ü jetzt gerade ein bisschen
durcheinander die Drittstaaten Frage ist
eine das funktioniert erkennbar nicht
dass Leute die in einem anderen EU-Staat
waren und dann durchgereicht werden das
müssen wir wieder ändern das war schon
mal anders und die Frage ob jemand in
einem vorgelagerten Land außerhalb der
Europäischen Union ein Asylantrag stellt
der dort geprüft wird da haben wir den
Auftrag das zu prüfen das werden wir
prüfen Sie haben ja selber das Beispiel
Großbritannien genannt es war der
Europäische Menschenrechtsgerichtshof
der das rechtstig erklärt hat den Flug
gestoppt hat und es wird jetzt gerade am
Supreme Court in Großbritannien geprüft
also ganz so einfach ist es
offensichtlich nicht und die
entscheidende Frage haben sie
angesprochen sie haben es auch gesagt
was passiert in dem Fall wenn die Leute
nicht zurück können bleiben die dann in
Albanien bleiben sie künftig in Ruanda
es ist alles nicht so trivial ich würde
mich mal
freuen das nur sagen darf ich würde mich
mal freuen wenn wir das was wir jetzt
beschlossen haben einfach mal umsetzen
und machen wir sind in Deutschland sehr
gut dabei sofort wieder in den
Parteienstreit in der C muss schauen wer
sich durchsetzt lassen sie uns da
einfach mal das Umsetzen wir haben doch
jetzt bei den letzten Landtagswahlen
gesehen am Ende profitieren die
Rechtspopulisten Linkspopulisten an
menarit
und sof mit dabei aber die
Zahlen die Zahlen müssen R wir müssen
etwas beschließen wo wir einigermaßen
sicher sind die illegale Migration
runtergt haben sie heute Statement vom
Chef der Bundespolizei gehört die Zahlen
gehen runter wegen einer Maßnahme und
das ist die Kontrollen an der Grenze
direkt an der Grenze hinter der Grenze
das hilft kurzfristig die anderen
Maßnahmen da gebe ich ihn recht die sind
eher mittel und langfristig gesehen wir
reden da auch ein bisschen über ein
Marathon und auch da müssen wir besser
werden aber dass jetzt alle die Absicht
haben das zu machen ist doch gut schauen
Sie ich könnte jetzt auch hergehen und
sagen die meiste Zeit hat die Union die
in Minister gestellt die Union stellt
die meisten Ministerpräsidenten die
meisten Innenminister aber es führt uns
doch nicht weiter lassen Sie uns die
zusammenar die maßnahen sind nur bezogen
auf Deutschland und nicht auf den Zuzug
und wir müssen auch über den Zuzug reden
sonst kommen wir nicht weiter dies
schlauen Frau die rechts neben ihnen sit
Sch die hat nämlich auch wirklich
richtig Ahnung victoria rietigch ist
herzlich begrüßt in unserer Sendung sie
ist die Leiterin des migrationsprogramms
bei der Deutschen Gesellschaft für
Außenpolitik und wir sind dankbar dass
Sie bei uns sind sie helfen uns erstmal
dabei zu erklären was in ihren Augen
wirklich zielführend und richtig ist den
Ländern jetzt mehr Geld zu geben diese
3,5 Milliarden helfen die wirklich
Fragezeichen ändern die etwas an der
großen Not der vielen Bürgermeister die
schon in dieser Sendung saßen der
Ministerpräsidenten diee
anschlossen hilft das ja ja das hilft
also die Pro Kopfpauschale von den 7500
€ dass die jetzt eingeführt wurde dass
jetzt dieses atmende System eingeführt
wurde das ist eine Forderung gewesen die
lange Zeit jetzt mitgeschwungen ist die
jetzt auch erfüllt wird und ich denke
das gibt äh das ist natürlich nicht das
Maximum dessen was gefordert war aber es
gibt eine Planbarkeit und das ja schon
mal was positives und das ist auch eins
der muss man sagen wenigen Punkte die ja
da ganz neu äh jetzt beschlossen wurden
es gibt noch andere die relativ neu sind
wie z.B die Leistungskürzung von denen
wir schon gesprochen haben oder auch
diese Kommission die jetzt eingesetzt
werden soll das ist alles neu aber sehr
viele Sachen da drin sind ja jetzt auch
schon so vier bis sechs Wochen alt also
alles was wir da über Rückkehr drin
gelesen haben und auch über
Binnengrenzkontrollen das haben wir
eigentlich schon das wurde jetzt schon
beschlossen auch in Gesetze teilweise
gegossen in letzten Wochen und dann
haben wir einfach sehr sehr viel und das
ist wichtig zu betonen dann haben wir da
sehr sehr viele Sachen die einfach alte
Hüte sind und die wir so oder so ähnlich
jetzt schon seit Jahren besprechen und
dazu gehört ne die gesreform dazu gehört
die verschnellerung von oder
Beschleunigung von
Asylverfahren mraabkommen drin Reform
gemin europäischen Asylsystems genau in
Europa genau und natürlich was da auch
was ja eigentlich auch ein alter Hut ist
ist eben die Prüfung der Möglichkeit
Asylverfahren in Drittstaaten
durchzuführen also es ist sehr
interessant dass wir das jetzt so heiß
diskutieren obwohl das natürlich seit
zwei Jahren schon im Koalitionsvertrag
stand wenn wir uns jetzt fragen was
bringt das denn eigentlich selbst Otto
Schil darüber schon nachdachte Jahre
2004 libyen war glaub ich also ein
Evergreen und eigentlich reden wir seit
den 90er Jahren über dieses über dieses
System und über diese Idee Asylverfahren
in in Drittstaaten auszulagern kann ich
auch gleich noch was zu sagen ja aber
erstmal wenn wir Fragen jetzt in der
Gesamtschau was bringen denn diese
Sachen da würde ich sagen die der Sinn
und Unsinn dieser Beschlüsse der steht
und fällt jetzt nicht so sehr mit dem
was da drin steht sondern da bin ich
ganz bei Ihnen her mit der Umsetzung ja
kriegen wir das diesmal umgesetzt denn
das ist in am Ende in Deutschland immer
das Problem wir sind immens schlecht
darin migration politische Beschlüsse
auf Bundesebene tatsächlich auch
umzusetzen und das liegt an zwei Gründen
zum einen haben wir ein externes Problem
wo wir mit Partnern arbeiten müssen in
Drittstaaten aber auch in der
Europäischen Union die schlichtwg nicht
mitmachen und dann haben wir ein
internes Problem dass wir wahnsinnig
ineffiziente Prozesse und Arbeitsteilung
haben zwischen bundländern und Kommunen
okay die dazu führen dass wir sehr
uneinheitlich umsetzen und dadurch auch
unfair umsetzen also wir haben unfaires
System in Deutschland und ganz ganz viel
Druck ist auf den Ausländerbehörden den
die absolut überfordert sind mit der
großen Komplexität die das
migrationsrecht mittlerweile angenommen
hat und die das ja alles umsetzen müssen
und deswegen wenn es etwas gäbe was wir
jetzt dringend machen sollten in der
nächsten Zeit um die Umsetzung dann auch
zu befördern ist genau in diese Stellen
zu investieren und zu investieren in das
Gesicht von Migrationspolitik nach außen
und das sind eben in Deutschland die
Ausländerbehörden weil das ist ja der
erste Anlaufpunkt wo Migranten in
Deutschland hingehen das ist deutsche
Migrationspolitik für die die
Ausländerbehörde ja und das ist kein
schönes Gesicht weil die
Ausländerbehörden alle komplett
überlastet sind und die Wartezeiten
Ewigkeiten sind und das mittlerweile so
normalisiert ist dass das nicht
funktioniert da ist einer der eins der
großen Probleme wie kann man das
Verändern mit mehr Menschen mit mehr
oder raus aus dieser kommunalföderalen
Struktur nur damit wir das einmal zu
Ende verstanden zum einen durch ganz
durch wesentlich mehr Investitionen weil
tatsächlich einfach Personalmangel da
ist ich weiß noch eine Vertreterin der
Ausländerbehörde mit der ich mE
Interview machte die sagte diesen
schönen Satz wissen sie in der Ausländer
Behörde muss man sich davon
verabschieden dass man seinen Job machen
kann das ist einfach überhaupt nicht
möglich weil die Anträge viel zu viel
sind und diese Situation müssen wir
ändern wo also dieses kleinste Glied
Ausländerbehörde so überlastet ist das
heißt da Investitionen rein aber wir
müssen auch strukturell wie wir
Migrationspolitik umsetzen tatsächlich
anders denken so ein furchbarer Ausdruck
also wir müssen umstrukturieren wir
müssen wirklich eine Reform machen
dessen wie wir Migrationspolitik machen
im Bereich der rückkehrpolitik ist es
ganz besonders augenfällig wenn wir
dieses große Ziel bessere
rückkehrpolitik mehr Abschiebungen wenn
wir das tatsächlich durchexerzieren
wollen dann kommen wir nicht drum herum
diese historisch gewachsene aber höchst
ineffiziente Struktur zu ändern sodass
wir mehr Zentralisierung haben ähm und
um dadurch eben auch eine fairere eine
effizientere und gleichzeitig auch eine
humanere migrations und rückkehrpolitik
auch aufzubauen so ich bin pragmatischen
Lösungen ich mein 2015 als eine Million
Menschen aus Syrien und anders anderen
Ländern gekommen sind haben wir alle
gedacht nach den Erfahrungen jetzt sind
alle außendebörden digitalisiert weit
gefehlt mein diese einfache Maßnahme
dass wir wissen wer ist wo woher dass
wir es erfassen in Deutschland und
europäischen den Außengrenzen ist
eigentlich eine Binse me der desaströse
Zustand unseres Landes was
Digitalisierung angeht übersetzt sich
auf den Zustand der außende behehörden
wie sie gesagt haben das ist z.B eine
Maßnahme die würde sehr schnell helfen
es ist gut dass der Kanzler da jetzt
massiv Druck macht dass alle auser
behehörden so schnell wie möglich
digitalisiert gewen wir die Ausländer
Behörden stönen auch er Herr weil
entschuldigung ich setze gleich noch
eine Frage oben drauf hat das
Niedersachsen vielleicht sogar schon auf
dem Zettel und arbeitet heftig daran
also wie in jedem anderen Flächenland
auch ist das sehr unterschiedlich aber
was jetzt ansteht bei uns ist auch ein
sehr intensiver Prozess zwischen dem
Land und den Kommunen möglichst schnell
alle Ausländerbehörden auf einen guten
digitalen Stand zu bringen und sie damit
übrigens auch attraktiver wieder als
Arbeitsplatz zu machen für viele
Menschen die dort eine
höchstverdienstvolle Arbeit leisten äh
ich ich will nur etwas sagen zur Kritik
von dezentralen Systemen also viele
Bürgermeisterinnen und Bürgermeister
werden begeistert bei dem Gedanken wenn
morgen der Bund erklären würde er ist
jetzt künftig zuständig für die
Unterbringung von geflüchteten Menschen
und das würde ein heilloses Chaos werden
das kann ich versprechen denn das ist in
vielen Fällen eine außerordentlich
kleinteilige Arbeit wo man sehr eng
miteinander zusammenarbeiten muss und
wie das zwischen der fernen
Bundesbehörde und der konkreten Kommune
vor Ort geschehen soll also das entzieht
sich meiner Fantasie das ist glaube ich
das das zählt zu den Vorschlägen die uns
eher weniger weiterbringen okay vortig
sie müssen returnieren natürlich nee da
stimme ich absolut zu die
Ausländerbehörden und alles was kommunal
ist sind genau dann gebraucht wenn es um
Unterbringung geht und um Integration
aber wenn es um Rückkehr geht also um
extegration sozusagen sollten wir da
eine größere Stringenz und eine größere
Einheitlichkeit haben weil es eben da
wichtig ist also es ist natürlich immer
wichtig die auf lokaler Ebene die die
Ausländerbehörden zu haben die
tatsächlich die Situation vor Ort kennen
um dann dort für eine anständige
Unterbringung zu suchen darüber hinaus
wäre ja auch eine Unterbringung die die
zentral organisiert ist ja auch Quatsch
also da hätten wir müssen wir uns
irgendwie riesige komplexe vorstellen
woer Menschen untergebracht werden das
ist selbstverständlich nicht sin Bich
der Integration aber im Bereich von
Rückkehr sehr wohl denn da haben wir
diese organisierte Desorganisation wo
600 Ausländerbehörden alle sehr
unterschiedliche Entscheidungen fällen
können und auch das befördert die
völlig richtige das oder diese völlig
richtige Annahme dass Abschiebung in
Deutschland am Ende sehr unfair sind
weil sie eben uneinheitlich beschlossen
werden und uneinheitlich umgesetzt
werden und weil wir wahrscheinlich eher
die abschieben die sich nicht Werren
können und die sich sogar melden weil
gut integrierte leichter abschiebbar
sind als weniger gut integriert und
deswegen haben wir einige Bundesländer
ohne Namen zu nennen die natürlich sehr
gut darin sind die Zahlen nach oben zu
treiben aber da haben wir dann eben auch
die Fälle von den gut integrierten
deckerlehrlingen die dann abgeschoben
werden hingegen haben wir andere
Bundesländer wo bungen weniger s
politisch gewollt sind und da haben wir
dann eine absurde Situation wo ein Fall
von einem straftätigen
ausreisepflichtigen trotzdem der sich
nicht mit der mit der Abschiebung
ernsthaft befassen muss also da wird das
einfach nicht durchgesetzt ja wir haben
den von dem Kanzler in Erinnerung ich
frage gleich die Politik den Satz aus
dem großen spiegelinterview das jetzt in
Größenordnung abgeschoben werden soll
Herr Wall sie können es wahrscheinlich
auch nachts sagen was der Bundeskanzler
ihnen da mit auf den Weg gibt was haben
sie im letzten halben Jahr diesbezüglich
in Niedersachsen gekonnt ich glaube es
sind 600 Abschiebung ne es sind schon
deutlich mehr also wir werden
wahrscheinlich bei über 1000 landen das
ist dann g eine Steigerung gegenüber der
dem letzten Jahr die wirklich groß ist
und das wird auch so weitergehen aber
meine Antwort auf die Abschiebung in
großem Stil wäre ja wir werden in großem
Stil mehr abschieben können wenn wir
vorher in großen Stil mehr
Rücknahmeabkommen haben den den ganz in
vielen Fällen scheitern Rückführung
schlichtweg daran dass die
Herkunftsstaaten nicht bereit sind ihre
Bürgerinnen und Bürger zurückzunehmen
und dann ist jeder Ausländerbehörde ganz
egal wo sie angesiedelt ist natürlich am
Ende ihres Lateins deswegen ist das
wirklich ein ganz entscheidender Punkt
wir sind Herr Linnemann auch bei einer
großen Forderung der Union endlich
abschieben wo sind die
Rückführungsabkommen der Bundeskanzler
soll Reisen das tut er in meiner
Wahrnehmung sage ich jetzt mal ganz
vorsichtig
warum kommen die so schlecht Zustande
mit den Ländern in die wir rückführen
wollen und führen wir vielleicht da auch
in die falschen zurück weil dann sind es
am Ende nur 600 die Ankommen in ich weiß
nicht Senegal müsen uns einfach mal
ehrlich machen in diesem Lande Herr weil
schiebt nicht mehr als 10% ab ich würde
jetzt mal tippen 6 7% derer die
eigentlich abgeschoben werden müssen in
den letzten 10 Jahren sind im
Durchschnitt jedes Jahr 270.000
Flüchtlinge nach Deutschland gekommen es
wurden nie mehr als 20.000 abgeschoben
also kein 10% wir müssen endlich in
Deutschland mal verstehen wir können
jetzt gerne wie der Kanzler noch eine
Superlative wählen und sagen wir
brauchen jetzt turboabschiebung und
vieles mehr wir brauchen einen Wechsel
dass nur noch Menschen zu uns kommen die
einen positiven Asylbescheid haben und
deswegen müssen wir über diese Punkte
reden frauner wir werden im Bundestag
alles wir werden alles wir werden
mitstimmen bei den bei fast allen
Punkten ja bei der Verlängerung was Frau
Quadbeck gesagt hat von den niedrigen
sozial Leistung von 18 auf 36 Monat wir
werden mitstimmen überall nur das
Kernproblem und dafür brauchen wir
m Herr özte mir eine da dafür sind wir
sofort bereit weil ich genau weiß dass
es sonst Wasser auf die Mühlen der
Populisten ist in Deutschland wenn wir
da nicht schaffen dass wir
parteiübergreifen wirklich ein großen
Wurf versuchen das ist aber kein großer
Wurf ein großer Wurf wäre die
drittstaatenlösung wäre dass wir
möglichst in Grenznähe wie Dänemark es
macht rückkehrzentren transitzentren
dass dort entschieden wird wer darf
bleiben wer nicht wer bleiben darf kommt
zur Kommune wer nicht bleiben darf muss
zurück die magrebstaren als sichere
Herkunftsstaaten titulieren den Familien
Familiennachzug stoppen die Abkommen bei
dem Bürgergeld müssen wir ran wir sehen
doch bei den arbeitsquoten das es ein
Anreiz ist ein pullfaktor selbst bei
ukin haben wir eine Quote von unter 20%
36 Monaten Polen über 50% in in arbeiten
die Menschen das sind Punkte wo wir dann
mal Befreiungsschlag hätten für dieses
Land stattdessen diskutieren wir hier
tagelang immer über das Thema abschieben
da können wir noch so viel machen wir
sehen bei Herrn weil er wird kein Jahr
es schaffen mehr als 10 % abzuschieben
ich mache auch Herrn walger keinen
Vorwurf ich will nur deutlich machen
dass wir so das Problem nicht lösen
sondern wir müssen die Kernfrage
beantworten wie schaffen wir es dass nur
noch Menschen zu uns kommen die im
positiven Asylbescheid haben es gibt
auch ab mit ja weil es so wichtig ist
wir haben auch ein Abkommen mit Tunesien
was gerade äh äh nicht nur beschrieben
wird sondern gelebt wird Italien mit
Albanien die denen sind bereit zu
kooperieren die Schweden Österreich
Italien wir haben immer mehr Länder die
sagen wir sind bereit und diesen Weg
müssen wir jetzt gehen und mein nicht
nur mein Gefühl die Grünen ich meine das
gar nicht gar nicht schon gar nicht
persönlich aber Frau lang hat gesagt sie
ist da raus bei der drittstaatenlösung
sie ist raus die Sozialleistung zu
kürzen und vieles mehr so wird es nicht
funktionieren so haben ich die Sendung
angefangen und die Frage hat der öste
mir schon beantwortet und sie hatten ja
vor die Grünen in der Ampel zu ersetzen
sind sie immer noch bereit in die
Koalition zu springen wenn Frau elner
die Ampel hat eine Mehrheit in
Deutschland die hat eine Mehrheit in
Deutschland ja die muss regieren dafür
ist sie gewählt demokratisch legitimiert
aber wir sind bereit bei so einem
wichtigen
themaforderung erleben überall in Berlin
in Berlin gehen 1700 Kinder nicht zur
Schule weil die weil die Kapazitäten
nicht da sind in Bremen gehen sie zur
Schule da fehlen die Lehrer wir sind am
Limit deswegen sind wir bereit einen
großen Wurf und nicht ver ein klar seit
anderthalb Jahren beklagen sich darüber
Bürgermeister und Ministerpräsidenten
und
ja Leute die kommunal tatsächlich an die
Grenzen kommen auch an die Grenzen ihrer
Kraft und jetzt müssen die Zahlen runter
wie gehen die Zahlen runter her Ö mir
mal unabhängig davon dass Frau lang und
herr Kretschmann zusammen ja tatsächlich
dieses Papier geschrieben haben und
genau diesen Satz sagen aber sie nehmen
mir ab ja danke das ist so das he
schauen Sie Herr
Lindemann schwäbisch sagt man brutler
wir können jetzt brutteln und und
schimpfen wie schlimm alles ist oder wir
sagen jetzt einfach mal wir fangen jetzt
an wir braucheneinander sie haben in den
Ländern eine Mehrheit wir haben den Bund
eine Mehrheit wir können uns gegenseitig
blockieren dann wird die AFD stärker und
wir sind in dem Land wie in den USA wo
die eine Hälfte mit der anderen nicht
mehr spricht oder wir machen es anders
ich glaube sie und ich sind uns einig
der Weg ist besser und jetzt fangen wir
an her weil hat ja schon ein paar
Argumente genannt schauen Sie wir machen
jetzt eine Maßnahme das ist ihr Argument
immer gewesen mit den pullfaktoren also
von 18 auf 36 Monate wir führen die
Karte ein das heißt es gibt kein Cash
mehr sonder eine Karte auf der anderen
Seite was wir ebenfalls machen ist dass
wir sagen bei denen das ja auch eine
Forderung von ihnen von anderen gewesen
5%
aufnahmewahrscheinlichkeit soll das
Verfahren und zwar komplett in 3 Monaten
abgeschlossen werden bei den anderen in
sechs Monaten das unterscheidet sich
deutlich von dem was wir
veraltungsrichter gerne machen einfach
mal machen ja das macht mehr aber da
brauchen wir auch Sie und Sie brauchen
uns do ist doch schön aber ich erinnere
Sie dann ab nächste Woche wieder dran so
und jetzt kommt ein weiter Punkt dazu da
hat sich ihre Kanzlerin dran forbiiert
und unser Kanzler macht's jetzt das ist
das was Herr weil zurecht angesprochen
hat das sind die Rücknahmeabkommen die
braucht mal weil schauen Sie virtuelle
Abschiebungen verändern nichts das haben
sie ja gerade beeindrucken geschildert
reale Abschiebungen gehen nur in reale
Länder dazu müssen die Länder bereit
sein ihre Bürger aufzunehmen da gibt's
ein potporie von Möglichkeiten das ist
manchmal leider möglicherweise Druck
manchmal sind Angebote indem man sagt
wir geben euch ein Angebot dass wir euch
bei der dualen Ausbildung helfen wir
geben euch eine Möglichkeit dass eure
Studierenden bei uns in Universitäten
studieren können und so weiter
wirtschaftliche Zusammenarbeit legale
ein Möglichkeiten übrigens Winfried
Kretschmann mein Ministerpräsident hat
es im westlichen Balkan damals her
vorgeschlagen es war sehr erfolgreich
wir haben gesagt Asyl aus dem westlichen
Balkan von Ländern die Mitglied der EU
werden können das passt nicht das ver ST
kein normaler Mensch aber eine legale
einreisemöglichkeit die ermöglichen wir
euch so dass ihr und wir planen können
das hat sehr gut funktioniert und dieses
Modell müssen wir jetzt Schritt für
Schritt auf die Länder Afrikas
übertragen lassen Sie mich noch eins
sagen ich bin ja auch
Landwirtschaftsminister es gehört auch
dazu da haben jetzt noch gar nicht
drüber geredet dass wir unseren Beitrag
dazu leisten dass Menschen nach
Möglichkeit ihre Heimat nicht verlassen
müssen ist jetzt auch nicht so dass
überall Menschen auf gepackten Koffern
sitzen und sich sagen ach wie schön wäre
es wenn ich meine Heimat verlasse das
hat mit kriegen zu tun das das hat mit
Umweltschäden zu tun das hat mit
Wirtschaftsordnung zu tun da können wir
schon auch als viertgrößte
Weltwirtschaft und als Europäische Union
Unterschied machen das gehört auch in
den Maßnahmen okay wir sind Frau
Quadbeck bei der großen Frage ob wir
diese Veränderung in der Politik diesen
neuen Blick auch auf Migration obwohl es
seit anderthalb Jahren wenigstens eine
große Klage darum gegeben hat eher eben
wirklich politischen Wahlen zu verdanken
haben auf jeed einen politischen
Stimmungswechsel ich würde gerne noch
ein Wort zu Herrn Lindemann sagen
Sie haben ja in vielen Punkten Recht
dass es gut wäre wenn etwas geschähe
dann ist es aber nicht so gut wenn sich
Ihr Parteivorsitzender nach so einer
Nacht hinstellt und sagt der
deutschlandpakt ist jetzt beendet
sondern das Signal hätte natürlich sein
müssen dass die Union sagt okay
substanzielle Maßnahmen aber es bedarf
sicherlich noch mehr also das finde ich
schon nicht so ganz redlich dann in so
einer Debatte und dann zu der Frage wie
ist der politische Stimmungs Wechsel
zustande gekommen ja das sind äh einmal
sicherlich die Wahlen in Hessen und in
Bayern gewesen insbesondere in Hessen
weil da nämlich klar war dass die AFD
auch in Westdeutschland angekommen ist
bisher hat man sich ja immer gerne
darauf rausgeredet halt so Problem in
Ostdeutschland und die haben die
Demokratie nicht verstanden aber nein
das ist natürlich mit nichten so sondern
die große Teile der Bevölkerung fühlen
sich von
insbesondere der ampelregierung einfach
nicht genug gesehen und gehört und ähm
auch wenn ich mich unterhalte
beispielsweise mit ähm
Meinungsforschern die sagen dass ähm
auch ihre Ergebnisse aus ihrer Sicht
nicht ähm ja nicht nicht wirklich
verstanden werden von der Politik nicht
angenommen werden und
ähm ich frage mich wird das jetzt
gelingen im nächsten halben Jahr dass
man tatsächlich solche Maßnahmen umsetzt
so wie Sie es gerade gesagt haben die
Maßnahmen müssten jetzt wirklich schnell
umgesetzt werden dass es einen spürbaren
Rückgang am Zustrom von ähm geflüchteten
Menschen nach Deutschland gibt oder
brauchen wir noch die Europawahlen damit
es dann doch noch mal Dung macht bei der
Politik und dass man wirklich das Signal
hört dann kommen im nächsten Herbst die
Landtagswahlen in Brandenburg in Sachsen
und in SachsenAnhalt wo überall die AFD
aktuell nach Umfragen Mehrheitspartei
ist und das ist eine wirklich
brandgefährliche Situation die aus
meiner Sicht immer noch nicht komplett
verstanden ist von der ampelregierung
sonst würde man tatsächlich jetzt auch
schon anders sprechen und sonst würde
man jetzt nicht äh noch mal darüber
reden geht der Beschluss oder geht der
Beschluss nicht sondern da würde man
sagen okay können wir in den nächsten zi
D vier Sitzungswochen vor Weihnachten äh
noch entsprechende gesetzesanträge
einbringen damit dann eben auch die
Wirksamkeit sich zeigt und her öste mir
in einem Punkt stimme ich Ihnen zu ich
glaube dass die Grenzkontrollen
tatsächlich was bewirken das ist gut
also die und das steht ja auch in dem
Papier drin dass die fortgesetzt werden
sollen und was eben auch noch wichtig
ist diese schleierfandung rund um die
Grenzen wo man dann eben vor allen
Dingen den Schleppern das Handwerk legt
es geht ja nicht nur darum dass man die
Menschen die nach Deutschland kommen
möchten aufhält oder ihn den Weg
versperrt sondern es geht ja vor allen
Dingen darum den Schlepper an das
Handwerk zu legen doch Einatz zu Frau qu
weil sie nicht
angesprochen ganz kurz sehr vieles
gesagt und auch sehr vieles gutes gesagt
aber ich würde gerne einen kleinen
Widerspruch Wagen in Richtung von Herrn
ö und auch von Herr linemann her was
gelingt also hier ist ja die Frage wie
schnell wird das gelingen was wir wenn
sie das noch mitnehmen
mittelfristig und langfristig also die
wenigsten migrationspolitischen
Maßnahmen wirken ja wirken ja wirklich
kurzfristig und schnell Grenzkontrollen
können natürlich immer so ein
kurzfristigen Effekt haben der aber dann
mittelfristig auch oft se wieder abnimmt
auch weil Schmuggler dann wieder einen
anderen Weg finden ne also deswegen das
meiste was wir machen ist sowieso eher
mittel und langfristig so Herr sie haben
viele wichtige Sachen gesagt unter
anderem auch ein Highlight gelegt auf
die Fluchtursachen was ein wichtiger
Punkt ist den wir derzeit in Deutschland
kaum besprechen das ist wichtig aber sie
haben auch so ein migrationsmytos
perpetuiert gerade oft gehört aber
trotzdem falsch nämlich dass wir zu den
Ländern gehen müssen mit Anreizen und
auch mit Sanktionsmöglichkeiten ein
bisschen Druck ausüen müssen und dann
machen diese Länder schon mit und unsere
Forschung hat sehr klar gezeigt ja das
ist natürlich legitim und auch wichtig
und richtig zu Ländern zu gehen und so
ein anreizpaket zu schnüren aus
positiven und negativen Anreizen aber
vorsicht das funktioniert meistens nur
bei wirklich kleinen Ländern die ohnehin
ein Stück weit von uns abhängig sind und
wo wir auch keine anderen geopolitischen
Interessen haben bei den Ländern die
wirklich für uns wichtig sind
migrationspolitisch sei es Türkei sei es
Marokko sei es Tunesien sei es Nigeria
haben unsere unsere Anreize unsere
positiven Anreize oftmals wenig Effekt
un Zuckerbrot ist da nicht wirklich süß
genug ja und unsere Drohungen und
Sanktionen die lassen die auch eher dort
kalt wir haben in unser beschreib in
unserer Forschung beschreiben wir das
als den Teflon Effekt dass eben diese
Drohungen so an ihnen abgleiten ja weil
die am Ende wissen und das ist ein
wichtiger Punkt ja klar sie ist Europa
wirtschaftlich mächtiger aber bei
Migrationspolitik sitzen diese Länder
oft am längeren Hebel und das wissen die
auch denn und das ist die dreckige
Wahrheit wir brauchen diese Länder in
der Migrationspolitik viel mehr als die
uns brauchen und das Nutzen mein Hinweis
ich habe extra draf hingewiesen Frau
Merkel hat sich schon dran probiert der
jetzige Bundeskanzler probiert sich dran
sie haben ja recht das ist eben nichts
was kurzfristig hilft darum sollt man
auch nicht den Eindruck erwecken als ob
wir jetzt quasi heute den archemedischen
Punkt haben mit dem wir das irgendwie
ausheben sondern wir müssen jetzt
endlich mal ins Handeln kommen und die
gute Nachricht ist die Politik hat das
verstanden die demokratischen Parteien
wollen da zusammenarbeiten hier und da
gibt's natürlich versuche der
Profilierung das gehört dazu auch
parteiinterne Geschichten das gehört in
der Demokratie auch dazu aber wenn wir
jetzt eben mal anfangen das Vertrauen
zurückgewinnen und das sind zwei Sachen
das ist zum einen die Frage dass wir der
Bevölkerung vermitteln wir mein das
ernst wir wissen wer zu uns kommt wir
kontrollieren und steuern das sorgen
auch dafür dass es vor Ort Anreize gibt
zu bleiben und zum anderen wir kümmern
uns auch um die Frage der Integration
beides gehört zusammen und in beiden
Stellschrauben müssen wir besser werden
und bis jetzt wissen wir eben überhaupt
nicht wer nach Deutschland kommt das ist
ja nach wie vor auch ein
sicherheitspolitisches Problem Stefan
weil so einfach ist das in der SPD auch
nicht durchzusetzen weil nicht nur in
den grünen Herr östemier kann sich kurz
erholen auch in der SPD gibt es heftige
KTI wir als SPD dürfen beim rhetorischen
Überbietungswettbewerb in der
Asylpolitik nicht
mitmachen das fordern von Abschiebungen
im großen Stil ist nicht nur
unsolidarisch sondern spielt am Ende den
falschen in die
Hände es gibt in der SPD aktuell beim
Asylrecht einen Kurs nach rechts und das
besorgt mich sehr jetzt ist es an der
Zeit dass Menschen in der SPD wie ich
das jetzt auch mache dagegen aufstehen
und klare Kante gegen diesen Kurs von
Nancy fer und Olaf Scholz
zeigen ganz klar die Frage haben die
beiden da nicht einen Punkt dass die
Grünen die SPD die Union in dieser
Schärfe darüber erst diskutieren seit es
Wahlergebnisse gibt wer zu spät kommt
den bestraft der wähle also zunächst mal
ich habe den Eindruck im Vergleich zu
der CDU und auch zu den Grünen ist im
Moment die SPD in dieser Hinsicht ein
Hort relativer Einigkeit das ist beiem
das ist bei einem solchen Thema auch
immer er unterschiedliche Auffassung
gibt in einer so großen Partei das liegt
auf der Hand aber im Kern geht es meines
sachtens um folgendes ich finde ich auch
dass wir aufpassen müssen dass wir nicht
sozusagen jeden Tag eine neue Sau durchs
Dorf treiben sondern dass wir vor allen
Dingen jetzt auch zeigen müssen dass wir
praktisch Vorankommen das war etwas was
glaube ich in der Diskussion z.B von
Frau rietig und Frau Quadbeck Frau
Quadbeck richtigerweise ja hervorgehoben
worden ist das ist das entscheidende und
ein Beispiel dafür ist ist insbesondere
auch das was derzeit an den Grenzen
passiert ein zweiter Punkt der mir
wichtig ist persönlich halte ich es für
absolut nahe liegend dass wir die Frage
von Zuwanderung eigentlich nur dann
vernünftig in den Griff kriegen wenn es
uns gelingt auf der europäischen Ebene
tatsächlich jetzt endlich zu einem
gemeinsamen Kurs zu kommen ich meine
wenn die Leute sich durch halbeuropa
nach Deutschland durchgeschlagen haben
dann liegt do auf der Hand dass es viel
schwieriger ist dann beispielsweise
Rückführung zu organisieren als wenn das
als wenn das dir
kann man sagen ja das entscheiden wir
nicht in Deutschland sonder in Brüssel
aber das ist meinesachtens wirklich ein
echter Schlüssel jedenfalls wesentlich
leichter oder wesentlich wirkungsvoller
als manches andere und am Ende scheint
es mir so zu sein und das hier die
Schwierigkeit dass nicht ein all
Heilmittel zur Verfügung steht sondern
wir müssen sehr unterschiedliche
Schrauben und Räder die einen größ die
anderen kleiner in Bewegung setzen das
darus ein wirklich vernünftiges und
wirksames System das ist übrigens der
Kern meinesachtens dieses Beschlusses
über dem wir her reden deswegen sind da
auch teilweise und richtigerweise Themen
angesprochen die gibt es schon längst in
der Diskussion aber die gehören zu einem
solchen Konzept dazu die munteren Bürger
dieses Landes haben auch überhaupt nicht
vergessen dass seit Jahrzehnten in
Europa darüber diskutiert wird Herr weil
und dass wir seit Jahrzehnten auf eine
Lösung warten und ich weiß nicht wie
viele Menschen sagen dass Dublin tot ist
aber wir immer noch den Ländern im Süden
Europas zumuten mit dieser riesigen Zahl
von Menschen klarzukommen oder eben
nicht klarzukommen hier ist meine Frage
wie groß ist der politische Druck wie
groß spüren Sie den Druck dass im
nächsten halb halben Jahr nennenswert
etwas geschehen muss ich glaube dass
erstens immer mehr europäische Staaten
auch selber von dem Problem irregulärer
Zuwanderung betroffen sind ich betone
irregulär deswegen weil die Mehrheit
derjen das muss man auch wissen die zu
uns kommen haben am Ende ein Schutzrecht
meistens auf der Basis der gfer
Flüchtlingskonvention 65% richtig hört
man nicht so oft ja ist so ist so und
deswegen sollten wir auch an der Stelle
wirklich versuchen sachlich zu bleiben
aber im immer immer mehr Länder sind
betroffen und wir sind auch noch nie so
nah an einer gemeinsamen europäischen
Asylpolitik gewesen wie derzeit D z.B
hoffentlich auch die polnischen Wahlen
geholfen und ich hoffe sehr dass wir es
vielleicht noch in diesem ansonsten muss
es Anfang des nächsten Jahres gelingen
noch in dieser Legislaturperiode des
Europäischen Parlaments tatsächlich
diesen europäischen Asyl kompromissin
bekommen also das wäre ein echter
Schritt vorwärts aus meiner Sicht wir
sind bei chem östemir der tatsächlich an
zu entspannten Eindruck macht
zwei große Teile gab es mal in den
Grünen bei den Grünen die Frage ist
würden Sie heute sagen dass sie mit
dieser Position in der Mehrheitsmeinung
ihrer Partei sind wir hören zunächst die
schon zitierte Ricarda lang und dann
eine junge Kollegin die Absenkung von
Sozialleistungen und die Auslagerung von
Asylverfahren in Drittstaaten sehe ich
kritisch die vorgesehenen
asylrechtsverschärfungen sind eine
Katastrophe und reihen sich in den
migrationspolitischen Rechtsruck ein
insbesondere die Leistungskürzungen und
die Auslagerung von Asylverfahren sind
unmenschlich unnötig und möglicherweise
rechtswidrig sind die beiden parteis die
jetzigen parteichfs der Grünen stark
genug diese wahrscheinlich kommenden
Entscheidungen Beschlüsse den Grünen
einzuimpfen also erstmal was Ricarda
lang sagt ist ja die Frage mit der
verlagung in Drittstaaten da haben wir
ein Prüfauftrag das wird geprüft das ist
kein beschloss so und das was die Grüne
Jugend sagt das Reiz ein bisschen an das
was sie hern weil ja auch gefragt hab
Jugendorganisation manchmal eben
grundlegend andere Dinge sagen das ist
so das halten wir aus wir sind eine
verlässlicher Partner in der Koalition
und wir werden die Beschlüsse fassen die
notwendig sind um das Gleichgewicht
zwischen Humanität einerseits und
Ordnung andererseits hinzukriegen wir
haben ja auch eine Verantwortung dafür
schauen Sie ich habe selber Vorfahren
die kommen aus der Türkei ich will dass
meine Kinder in einem Land aufwachsen
dass sich zu liberalen Demokratie
bekennt und nicht kippt Richtung
Rechtspopulismus wenn wir das verhindern
wollen dann haben wir eine Verantwortung
dafür dass wir die Mehrheit in der Mitte
stabil halten und dazu gehört auch dass
wir den Leuten vermittel wir sind ein
humanitäres Land das den Menschen
zugewandt ist diejenigen die Not sind
die können sich drauf verlassen dass wir
Ihnen helfen aber diejenigen die nicht
in Not sind das ist ja der
wesensbestandteil des Grundrechts auf
Asyl dass man eben auch negativ
bescheiden kann die müssen das Land
verlassen und das haben wir in der
Vergangenheit nicht gut genug hinkriegt
hingekriegt das müssen wir besser
hinkriegen da haben wir auch eine
Verantwortung gerade um die zu schützen
die sich zurecht drauf berufen dass sie
hier Schutz brauchen ja wie groß wird
der Streit bei den den Grünen da gibt's
Ende November einen Parteitag da meln
sich jetzt schon manche Ringen wir das
das gehört zur Demokratie dazu so wie
alle Parteien Ringen den einen ist zu
wenig den anderen ist zu viel das gehört
der Demokratie dazu entscheiden ist doch
dass wir uns bei wichtigen Fragen nehmen
Sie den schrecklichen Angriff der Hass
auf Israel nehmen sie den Krieg in der
Ukraine Russlands Angriffskrieg auf die
Ukraine und jetzt eben diese Frage wo
unsere Kommunen zum Teil an ihre Grenze
kommen dass wir da zusammenrücken und
eben jeder muss ein Schritt aufeinander
zugehen da sind ja auch viele Dinge drin
die die Grünen gefordert haben andere
Dinge drin die andere Sozialdemokraten
liberale Christdemokraten gefordert
haben und jetzt versuchen wir in der
Mitte des Land zusammenzuhalten ich
glaube das ist allerhrenwert fragen wir
die politische Journalistin in der Runde
hat haben die Grünen schon in
klimapolitischen Fragen zu viele Kröten
geschluckt dass die eine Kröte mehr
jetzt irgendwie auch nicht mehr schlimm
ist ich glaube das wird ein Parteitag
werden vom 23 bis zum 26 November bei
dem man schon sehr gut wird sehen können
unter welchem Druck die Grünen stehen
einmal in der Koalition wo sie viele
Kompromisse machen müssen aber auch ähm
innenptisch stehen sie unter drrück also
die Union war ja bisher auch durchaus
immer ein potenzieller Koalitionspartner
für die Grünen die Union setzt sich im
Moment sehr stark ab von den Grünen wir
können das beispielsweise in Hessen
sehen wo jetzt zu erwarten ist dass es
eben eine schwarzrote Koalition gibt und
die schwarzgrüne Koalition von der
eigentlich alle meinten dass sie doch
recht erfolgreich regiert hat in Hessen
und ja eigentlich auch wieder gewwählt
worden ist ähm die ist dann eben passe
und das wird sich auf dem Parteitag
spiegeln also Druck von zwei Seiten
einmal Partei intern haben wir zu viele
Kröten geschluckt und dann aber auch der
gesellschaftliche der gesellschaftliche
Druck von außen der auf die Grünen ja
tatsächlich teilweise auch
boshaft stattfindet und wo die Grünen
sich
auch sehr vielen Anfeindungen die über
sachliche Kritik ja an den Positionen
die die Grünen ver vertreten weit hinaus
geht und eigentlich ist es ja ein
Parteitag wo der Vorstand gewählt werden
soll wo ein Europa Programm
verabschiedet werden soll ich kann mir
schon vorstellen dass sowohl bei den
Vorstandswahlen sich Unzufriedenheit
zeigt und das ist ja typisch für grünen
Parteitage man wird sicherlich auch
Beschlüsse sehen die einen in verstauen
versetzen man nennt das dann
Ventilfunktion also da wo die Partei
dann mal mir also da noch mal die
konkrete Frage sie müssen dann auch
sowas wie diese Bezahlkarte
verargumentieren sie müssen sagen dass
es einen Unterschied macht jetzt mal zu
Ende gedacht ein Unterschied macht wie
eigentlich auch Zahlen senken soll wenn
wir
Asylbewerbern nicht mehr äh Geld sondern
Sachleistungen und diese Bezahlkarte
geben können Sie das verargumentieren
ist keine grüne Forderung gewesen DAF
hat ich kein Geheimnis ist aber auch
nichts neues es gab's auch in der
Vergangenheit schon die Länder haben es
nicht eingeführt weil sie so
bürokratisch zu teuer war jetzt soll es
bundeseinheitlich geregelt werden
ähnlich wie die Frage von gemeinnütziger
Arbeit auch das ist nichts Neues gab es
in der Vergangenheit schon bei uns im
bahenwürdenberg hat es eine Gemeinde
schwäbischmüt gemacht also ist alles
nicht neu wir werden das was wir da
beschlossen haben umsetzen und dann
werden wir sehen wie es sich auswirkt
wie es sich auswirkt Herr weall wie
erklären Sie den Bürgern ihres Landes
dass die Bezahlkarte jetzt den
Unterschied macht die Zahlen der
Menschen die kommen werden ja nicht
runtergehen wir behandeln sie nur
schlechter na erstmal vermeide ich
tatsächlich Übertreibung das trägt schon
mal sehr zur Glaubwürdigkeit bei nach
mein Erfahrung ich sag nämlich nicht
dass das irgendwie jetzt äh die Antwort
auf alle Fragen wäre ich sage erstens
wenn es klappt dann wird die Verwaltung
wesentlich erleichtert wden und jeder
versteht dass die Kommunen insbesondere
die Ausländer behehörden an dieser
Stelle wirklich jede Entlastung
verdienen und zweitens sage ich und wenn
es dann noch klappt dann können wir
vielleicht dazu beitragen dass es
deutlich weniger Überweisung aus
Deutschland Richtung der Heimatländer
gibt denn das ist bekannt dass z.B viele
Familien aus Nordafrika ihre Söhne
versuchen nach Europa zu schicken damit
sie dort Geld äh verdienen und das dann
nach Hause schicken können das ist
ehrenwert und ich verstehe die
Motivation aber das ist nicht der Sinn
z.B unserer Sozialleistung ob das
gelingt oder nicht das werden wir jetzt
sehen denn das ganze Thema ist absolut
sagen Fachleute schwierig deswegen hat's
ja bis jetzt auch noch nicht geklappt
aber wir machen einen sehr ernsthaften
Anlauf genau also Bürgermeister
schüttelten auch hier in der Sendung
schon den Kopf und sagten das braucht
ganz viele Menschen das braucht ganz
viel Organisation aber erstmal halten
wir fest sagen Sie es wäre nicht ganz so
schlimm wie gar kein Geld mehr zu geben
oder nur noch Sachleistungen weil die
Menschen wenigstens mit dieser
Bezahlkarte Dinge erwerben könnten
natürlich und wir sind uns auch einig
das hat ein paar Diskussionen gedauert
aber jetzt ist es glaube ich Konsens es
muss auch ein Restbestand an Bargeld
geben und es kann nicht alles sozusagen
nur einsortiert sein in bestimmte
Warengruppen das sagt übrigens auch das
Bundesverfassungsgericht aber noch
einmal wenn es gelingt dann ist das ein
richtiger Schritt vorwärts und das wäre
eine dieser kleineren Schrauben über die
ich geredet habe okay wir sind bei Frau
rietig sie holt schon Luft jetzt kommt
der Satz der sze heraus damit bringt
nichts bringt wenig bringt wirklich
wenig also ich meine es ist ja schon
angeklungen ja und das muss man auch
einfach noch mal ganz klar sagen und ich
glaube dass dieser Satz ist schon in
allen Medien drauf und runter wir haben
alle schon gehört Sozialleistungen sind
einfach ein Faktor unter ganz vielen die
Deutschland attraktiv machen aber es ist
nicht der ausschlaggebende Faktor viel
wichtiger sind Familie und Freunde und
die Möglichkeit dass ich in Deutschland
Geld verdienen kann so das Senken dieser
Sozialleistung oder das spätere anheben
dieser Sozialleistung ist es ja
eigentlich ja das spart uns vielleicht
ein bisschen Geld ich glaube die Welt
wird das nicht sein ein bisschen Geld
spart das das kann man unter diesem
Voraussetzung dann als positive achten
dass der Staat g genau der stat Geld
spart dass das in irgendeiner Form
tatsächlich die irreguläre Migration
reduziert merklich reduziert das ist
absolut eine über kein anderes Land in
Europa das ist ja das
Argument viel Geld für geduldete oder
auch abgelehnte asylbber autau deswen
ist es auch absolut moralisch und
juristisch vertretbar dass Deutschland
das natürlich auch senkt aber Vorsicht
wir haben zwei Sachen die wir da
beachten sollten das eine ist das
natürlich das Bundesverfassungsgericht
uns eine Grenze vorgibt das
Existenzminimum gilt für alle unabhängig
V Aufenthaltsstatus und solange sich das
jetzt nicht ändert oder wir nicht
umdefinieren was das Existenzminimum ist
solange haben wir da eben einen eine
eine eine Deckel wo wir nicht runterkmen
ist Entschuldigung wirigen braen diese
euweite Angleichung habe ich auch von
ihnen gehört zu den sozileistung und was
wir da natürlich vergessen ist d es zwar
in der EU alle gleich sind aber einige
doch gleicher und z.B Dänemark ja ein
optout hat zu zu der Asyl geset oder zum
Asylrecht Europas und deswegen die ihre
Leistungen ja auch weiter senken können
als das Deutschland oder andere
europäische Länder tun können das heißt
wir können ein race to the bottom machen
aber einiger bottom in Europa ist eben
nochunter auf den Boden ich übersetze
jetzt nur
genau der
immerefelagen genau und und der
allerletzte Punkt bitte lass mich den
noch machen weil ich glaube der den
haben wir tatsächlich noch gar nicht
besprochen auch so in der Debatte in
Medien haben wir den Punkt nicht
besprochen wir reden davon dass
Deutschland attraktiv wird durch die
staatlichen Sozialleistungen aber wir
reden nie davon dass ja die staatlichen
Leistungen nur eine Seite der Medaille
sind und die nichtstaatlichen Leistungen
auch ein wahnsinnig wichtige Rolle
spielen nämlich in Form der sehr guten
integrationsinfrastruktur getragen durch
Zivilgesellschaft und eh amtler mm wir
haben in Deutschland über viele Jahre
aufgebaut diese Systeme dass äh es es
sehr viele Hilfen gibt für Menschen die
bei uns ankommen das aktive haben genau
also es ist hängt natürlich auch an
unserer Vereinskultur dass das S weit um
sich greift aber Deutschlands
integrationsinfrastruktur durch die
Zivilgesellschaft ist viel stabiler als
die unserer Nachbarn wo das einfach
nicht so in der Kultur schon mit drin
ist und wo es auch nicht so stark
staatlich gefördert wurde das heißt je
weniger der stat
hablich die Dieben und wir müssenürlich
davonusen Stück weit wenn wir eine
staatliche Leistung absenken die auch
gepuffert wird durch die
nichtstaatlichen Leistungen die
existieren und das ist eben wieder ein
noch ein weiterer Faktor oder noch ein
weiterer Grund warum eben wir wirklich
dann nicht von großen Effekten ausgehen
können also ich finde dass die Fakten
Bände sprechen die meisten Flüchtlinge
kommen nach Deutschland das Bürgergeld
ist sehr attraktiv einfach mal mit
Bürgermeistern reden mit Leuten v auch
in Deutschland das das das Kernproblem
ist wir den
in Deutschland man kann schwarz arbeiten
in Deutschland ja aber es ist doch so
das ist do komischerweise so dass die
meisten in Deutschland Sozialleistung
beziehen und nicht arbeiten gehen in den
anderen Ländern gehen sie arbeiten es
ist also ein Anreizes Bürgergeld um nach
Deutschland zu kommen und auch die
Deutschen die hier leben aber das soll
ja jetzt auch geändert werden her
interess möchte ich möchte einm ich habe
jetzt die ganze Zeit zugehört V wirklich
fast eine halbe Stunde fast eine halbe
Stunde hab stimt überhaupt nicht das wer
wir so 20 Minuten nein wir können das ja
hinter nachholen wollte nur mal einmal
das Argument zu Ende bringen wir können
gerne jetzt noch über diese ganzen
Details reden wir hatten in den 90er
Jahren eine Situation wo sehr viele
Flüchtlinge nach Deutschland kamen und
da gab es parteiübergreifend einen
deutschlandpakt nennen wir es mal so da
hat die SPD mitgemacht die FDP hat
regiert und die CDU und das gab in ihrem
Bundesland in Baden-Württemberg da waren
die Republikaner sehr stark und durch
das Asylgesetz Änderung durch die
Änderung des
diebler runter die Populisten das haben
wir damals geschafft wir haben auch mit
dem türkeikommen es geschafft und mit
der Schließung der Balkanroute dass die
Zahlen runtergingen Frau Quadbeck und
gleichzeitig gingen die Populisten
runter wir sehen das jetzt in denemark
weniger als 3% die Zahlen gehen runter
deswegen können sie nicht einfach sagen
ich meine das wirklich vorsichtig aber
Politik machen sie mit Überzeugung und
wir müssen unserer Überzeugung folgen
wir machen gerne bei den ganzen kleinen
Punkten mit aber wenn unsere Überzeugung
ist dass dieser deutschlandpakt der
angekündigt wird nicht zum Ergebnis
führt dass die illegale Migration
bekämpft wird schaffen wir genau das
Gegenteil dann wird die AFD in
Deutschland durch die Decke gehen und
deswegen haben wir die Tür nicht
abgeschlossen sie ist zu wir machen Sie
jederzeit auf weil wir ein ernsthaftes
Interesse haben die illegale Migration
zu senken da sind wir sofort bereit aber
wir können nicht bei solchen Sachen
mitmachen und sagen das ist ein
Deutschland das ist genauso wenn ich den
Punkt noch sagen darf wie das
Staatsangehörigkeitsrecht hängt auch
damit zusammen wo sie jetzt mit den
Grünen meine ich ganz vorsichtig ich
will es nur sagen ein
Staatsangehörigkeitsrecht schaffen wo
man nicht erst nach 5 Jahren die
deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft bekommen
kann in Ausnahmefällen sogar nach 3
Jahren man darf sogar vorbestraft sein
man darf eine Freiheitsstrafe haben man
darf in einer Situation sein wo man
selbst den gesamt Lebensunterhalt nicht
selbst verdient und trotzdem kriegt man
die deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft vor we
da müssen wir doch unserer Überzeugung
folgen und sagen das muss gestoppt
werden deshalb sind wir konstruktive
Opposition und so macht man Pol ist noch
ein interessanter Punkt Sekunde das ist
ein interessanter Punkt wir müssen es
alle verstehen es ist tatsächlich ein
großes Ziel dieser Ampel gewesen Frau
rtig hilft uns noch mal zu sagen hier
ist unser Angebot wir möchten geduldete
also nicht anerkannte sondern geduldete
und gegebenenfalls abgelehnte
Asylbewerber nicht so lange in diesem
Status en wir möchten Ihnen
schnellarbeit geben und wir möchten sie
dann gegebenenfalls auch einbürgern und
diese Zeiten verkürzen ist das ein
pullfaktor da werden wir uns sicherlich
noch lang zu streiten also die
Ampelkoalition innerhalb des
Paradigmenwechsel hatte sehr
verschiedene Maßnahmen davon ist eine
dieses chanceneinwanderungsgesetz also
geduldete aus dem duldungsstatus
rauszubringen das ist hat auch
tatsächlich schon einige zahlenmäßige
Effekte gebracht weil die Zahl der
ausreislichtungen tatsächlich zum ersten
Mal seit sehr langer Zeit gefallen ist
um mehrere 10000 Personen
die jetzt in diesem probestatus drin
sind so das ist eins das
Staatsbürgerschaftsrecht soll reformiert
werden da ist jetzt erst noch das ist ja
hängt ja immer noch und da ist das Ziel
eine Angleichung zu dem was andere
vergleichbare Länder durchaus haben
nämlich nicht diese Wartezeit von 8
Jahren sondern eine Wartezeit von 5
Jahren was durchaus andere Länder
haben und die Frage ist aber am Ende
welche Bedingungen stellen wir daran
wenn wir sagen nach 5 Jahren das ist die
zeitbedingung n eine von ganz vielen ja
dann kann man natürlich noch jede Menge
andere Bedingungen dran hängen ne inwi
weit zu welchen logischerweise muss man
sich dem Grundgesetz bekennen aber man
kann natürlich noch einen großen
Forderungskatalog aufstellen zu
Einkommen zu Vorstrafen oder nicht zu
Existenz das sind alles Sachen die wir
jetzt eben diskutieren da ist ja das
letzte Wort noch nicht gesprochen auch
deswegen hängt ja dieses Gesetz nach wie
vor wichtige aber politische frag noch
ein Punkt da
noch ja klar ist es wichtig dass wir
festlegen gesetzlich wer das kriegen
soll und wer nicht ganz wichtig aber
auch hier wieder vorsichtig die
Umsetzung die armen Behörden die jetzt
diese vielen Fälle dann bearbeiten
werden müssen da muss die Investition
passieren egal welche Kriterien wir
anchlussen wenn wir wollen dass das ein
Effekt hat müssen wir da investieren in
die Bürgerämter oder in die
neueschaffenen Behörden wie in Berlin wo
das jetzt geschieht die dann diesen
massiven Stapel bearbeiten müssen und
wir haben jetzt schon eine
Bearbeitungszeit von durchchnittlich
zwehalb Jahren in ber okay schnell die
worort aus Berlin her östem mir und dann
noch aus Hannover also zum einen die
kettenduldunge dass man das noch mal
klar Zehen das ist ja auch eine
Forderung gewesen von vielen
Christdemokraten dass wir mit diesem
irrsin aufhören dass Leute von denen wir
wissen dass sie nicht zurückgehen können
weil sie aus Ländern kommen die
irgendwie nicht mehr existieren kaputt
sind und so weiter die aber hier nicht
arbeiten dürfen kein Sprachkurs bekommen
das doch nachgerade absurd jahrelang auf
staatliche Hilfe angewiesen sind das
macht doch Sinn dass die Arbeiten
integriert werden auch wenn sie V allem
eine Ausbildung machen unserem Handwerk
gut tun unserem Mittelstand gutun das
mal das eine das ist eine sinnvolle
Maßnahme also wenn sie jetzt keine
Parteipolitik machen geben Sie mir recht
das zweite zum statsigkeit ja aber es
ging ja gerade um die Kettenduldung auch
zum staatsingehörigkeitsrecht Schauen
Sie wir haben das ja mit eingeführt dass
die freiheitlich demokratische
Grundordnung des Bekenntnis dazu
Voraussetzung ist jetzt im Lichte auch
der aktuellen Situation werden wir es
verschärfen wir werden noch mal
ausdrücklich reinnehmen dass das Thema
Antisemitismus wenn man sich dazu in der
Vergangenheit geäußert hat rein nehmen
wir werden auch die Möglichkeit noch mal
verschärfen dass bis zu 10 Jahre der
Pass auch wieder aberkannt werden kann
wenn jemand unter Vortäuschung falscher
Tatsachen das in Anspruch genommen hat
also linemann lassen Sie uns lassen Sie
uns bei dem Thema bitte seriös bleiben
weil
das auf der h auf der Homepage des
Bundesinnenministerium steht der
freiheitstrafen dass man die haben darf
und trotzdem D die die deutsche
Staatsbürgerschaft bekommt versch
letzter Punkt weil sie die 90er
angesprochen haben ein der Gründe warum
ich 1994 in den Deutschen Bundestag
kandidiert habe waren die damals die
rassistischen Übergriffe von Möllen
Rostock Lichtenhagen und so weiter das
war damals auch das Klima und es war
nicht gut dass wir in der Politik damals
das haben laufen lassen und dann quasi
den Eindruck erwckt haben wir geben dem
nach es ist immer besser wenn die
Politik vor derwe ist und schaut dass
sie die Kontrolle nicht verliert von
daher ist glaube ich auch ganz wichtig
wie wir über das Thema reden das zu viel
ist der meint des Guten Herr Linnemann
man muss auch ein bisschen aufpassen
dass wir drauf achten welche Worte wir
wählen ich bin bei jedem Wort extrem
vorsichtig dass ich auf der einen Seite
klar mache wir werden das ändern wir
meinen das ernst aber auf der anderen
Seite auch nicht dass es bei den
falschen einzahlt und da muss sich
glaube ich jeder demokratische Politiker
immer an die eigene Nase fassen Herr
weil die Frage ist jetzt doch noch mal
eine in die Aktualität hinein nächste
Woche wird Olaf Scholz Rip Erdogan die
Hand schütteln müssen dem Präsidenten
der mit mit uns tatsächlich einen
Abkommen abgeschlossen hat und 3,5
Millionen syer aufgenommen hat mit der
EU nicht nur mit Deutschland der auf der
anderen Seite aber die Hamas für eine
Befreiungsarmee hält und das
Existenzrecht Israels
anzweifelt sind das genau diese
Kompromisse diese
unendlichen ja dreckigen Geschäfte die
wir machen müssen wenn wir etwas an
diesen Zahlen ändern wollen ich gehe
davon aus dass Olaf Scholz den
Gesprächen mit Herrn Erdogan wirklich
auch klartex in in dieser Hinsicht redet
das ist absurd das muss man sagen
und auf der anderen Seite haben wir ein
Interesse daran dass wir mit der Türkei
im Gespräch bleiben auch das ist ja
offenkundig das ist wie bei vielen
anderen internationalen Fragen auch wir
können uns leider nicht aussuchen in
welchen Fällen in welchen Ländern W
regiert sondern da muss man die Dinge so
nehmen wie sie sind alles andere wäre
einigermaßen naiv und von da aus dann
weitermachen also deswegen find ich
richtig ich finde es richtig dass dieses
Gespräch stattfindet darf ich noch eine
Bemerkung machen V ich find es richtig
gut dass der deutschlandpakt in Sachen
Migration eben doch nicht erledigt zu
sein scheint wie Friedrich MZ gesagt hat
sondern dass wir die Tür wieder
aufmachen
sollenich und wenn erledigt hat er
gesagt aber wenn sich 16
Ministerpräsident mit fünf parteibüchern
einen können verstehe ich gar nicht
warum die Bundespolitik sich nicht
einigen können soll gut dann nehmen wir
das mal als ein Schlusswort und komme
ich komme wieder sie kommen sie alle
kommen hoffentlich hoffentlich wieder
und wir geben zügig an Markus Lanz der
heute unter anderem Jens spah zu Gast
hat ich darf mich ganz herzlich für eine
gute Diskussion hier heute Abend
bedanken vielen Dank auch nach Hannover
und schon bis nächste Woche 22:15 Uhr
wenn Sie
[Musik]
mögen